la guerra ideológica hace estragos en
Florida y divide a las familias
estadounidenses
muchos padres acusan a la escuela
pública de limitarse a doctrinar a sus
hijos con una ideología uoc
término que se ha convertido en sinónimo
de extra progresismo pero que
originalmente significa atento a la
desigualdad
Catalina es la presidenta del grupo
Monster Liberty madres por la libertad
un grupo conservador que hace campaña
por la prohibición de ciertos libros en
las escuelas
recuerdo que mi hijo menor se me acercó
a los seis años y me preguntó qué
significaba ser gay es vergonzoso tener
que hablar de estas cosas con niños
pequeños pero vivimos en un mundo en el
que si no se les enseña a hacer ellos
mismos Entonces el gobierno les va a
enseñar según su ideología
ya no confiamos en el sistema escolar
los cuatro hijos de Catalina van a la
escuela pública su hija mayoría Marí
tiene 16 años y también culpa a los
profesores de influir en su generación
me da igual que alguien sea gay o hetero
que se sienta chico o chica pero no es
el colegio quien debe decirnoslo
nuestras decisiones son nuestras si
Queremos saber más investigamos y si
alguien se siente así que lo averigüe
por sí mismo pero no necesitamos que nos
metan esas ideas en la cabeza si no
estaban ahí
los derechos de los padres están en el
centro de La retórica republicana Porque
si hay una cuestión que trasciende las
líneas partidistas es la crianza de los
hijos
nos hemos convertido en el nuevo partido
político Este es el año de los padres
estamos atentos y queremos que nuestros
derechos sean la primera prioridad en
este país
Miami históricamente demócrata ha
reelegido al conservador ron de santis
al frente del estado de Florida
es el abanderado de la guerra ideológica
y por ello ataca la educación en el
distrito lgbtq más de South Pitch este
activista está armado
amo Florida es mi hogar pero ahora mismo
está siendo atacada por congresistas y
rondesatis que quieren convertirla en un
lugar peligroso para la gente que se
parece a mí
el año pasado los legisladores de
Florida aprobaron un texto para reducir
la enseñanza de temas relacionados con
la orientación sexual o la identidad de
género
la medida apodada no digas gay por sus
oponentes
quiere ampliar la ley de no digas gay
prohibiendo los pronombres que la gente
elige para identificarse pero la escuela
por definición es un lugar de
aprendizaje de debate abierto que aborda
temas que de otro modo los niños ni
siquiera conocerían
la batalla contra los no se detiene en
cuestiones de identidad de género el
gobernador de Florida también está en
una lucha firme por la forma en que se
enseñan las desigualdades raciales en la
universidad internacional de Florida los
profesores Están preocupados nuestras
condiciones de trabajo son sus
condiciones de aprendizaje
y sus condiciones de aprendizaje son la
base de la economía aquí en Florida
no solo está en juego el estatus de los
profesores sino su libertad para enseñar
Cómo deseen en el estado
a principios de 2022 la legislatura de
Florida ya había aprobado la ley hb7 más
conocida como
prohíbe la enseñanza del privilegio
blanco en las escuelas esta vez un nuevo
proyecto de ley va más allá pretende
eliminar los programas de diversidad y
los cursos relacionados con las teorías
de raza y género en las universidades
públicas
un proyecto de ley que ron de santis no
debería tener problema en aprobar como
explica este profesor de filosofía
antes podíamos confiar en los aliados
que teníamos en el congreso y la
legislatura estatal
una legislación como esta no tenía
ninguna posibilidad de ser aprobada
pero desde las últimas elecciones que
eligieron la nueva gobernación de Santi
se siente libre de aprobar cualquier
legislación que quiera
está dispuesto a sacrificar estas
instituciones que innumerables personas
han pasado años construyendo por sus
ambiciones políticas nacionales
ron de santis aún no lo ha anunciado
pero todo apunta a que el republicano se
presentará a las elecciones
presidenciales de 2024
Erick scar dice que sus ataques a la
educación pública están diseñados para
silenciar a la oposición
si la educación está en la mira es
porque es la amenaza más importante para
las élites en una democracia los
profesores tienen miedo y para eso están
diseñadas estas leyes sólo para lograr
resultados concretos
son vagas y casi imposibles de cumplir
quieren asustarnos para que nos
autocensuremos
al insistir en políticas altamente
simbólicas en educación ron de santis
convence a todos los republicanos la
guerra ideológica promete estar en el
centro de las primarias y podría unir a
un partido ahora dividido